[Música]
crecí en los años 90 sin tele pero
viendo películas en formato blu-ray no
es algo así como el abuelo del bluray
veía una y otra vez 2001 odisea del
espacio me encantaba los diálogos de
fellini
me hipnotiza da en los mundos de akira
kurosawa
años más tarde y siendo igual de ñoña y
esta industria del cine tan maravillosa
jerárquica opaca me llevó a realizar una
investigación sobre cómo algunos
documentales estaban consiguiendo
financiación directamente desde de sus
audiencias
y fue tras un largo periplo que
eventualmente escuché sobre block change
se acordarán de pelis como la hora de la
siesta resultó culpable la tempestad
hoy son blast
a mi generación nos tocó vivir profundos
cambios y nos tocó adaptarnos a los
cambios de la tecnología y formatos hoy
por suerte esta tecnología va mucho más
allá de las redes sociales y de
del entretenimiento
toda esta historia empezó con
plataformas como bittorrent o napster
las cuales eran útiles para intercambiar
archivos entre pares
la tecnología logía blogs e ignacio en
2008 como una reacción casi cyberpunk a
la crisis económica de 2008 y se le
atribuye a un grupo o persona de nombre
satoshi nakamoto bloque es tan
importante porque implica una disrupción
como en su momento fue el acceso público
de internet que sólo estaba limitado
para uso militar
y seguramente conocen muy bien bitcoin
pero justo no les voy a hablar de esta
cripto moneda sino de todas las
posibilidades que tienen para ser
aplicado en cuestiones sociales en
tecnología cívica y por supuesto en las
tres creativas
si nosotros pensamos en este concepto de
cadena de bloques lo que vamos a
encontrar es al centro información o
datos que tienen una ruta hacia adelante
es decir que se direccionan a una
computadora siguiente y también que
marcan un registro de dónde viene y así
se van replicando en miles de millones
de dispositivos móviles a lo largo de
todo el planeta
hay algunos atributos de blogs para mí
hay cuatro muy importantes una es que es
una red descentralizada es decir todos
los nodos son igualitos no hay ninguno
que centralice esta información la
segunda es la seguridad todo toda
información está encriptada y esto la
vuelve bastante poderosa la tercera es
la seguridad
y la privacidad de los datos porque hoy
resulta que toda la información que
nosotros estamos inyectando en redes
sociales son plataformas no nos
pertenece entonces va haciendo ahora que
si nosotros estamos generando esta
información sea de nosotros y finalmente
el cuarto punto por lo cual yo considero
muy potente es la democratización porque
cualquiera puede unirse a esta red de
blogs change no sólo la gente que tiene
acceso a grupos privilegiados
quizá probablemente tengamos una visión
o una imagen más gráfica de block change
si pensamos un libro con té contable
donde están registrados los ingresos y
los gastos que el cual está actualizado
cada diez minutos 24/7 cada miembro de
esta red tiene una partecita del libro y
se va replicando por lo cual es muy
difícil de hackear una con millones de
computadoras
la magia de block change radica en que
elimina a terceros o intermediarios en
este caso a los bancos a las
instituciones y a las corporaciones que
se han encargado de proveer confianza o
seguridad como los bancos que nos
proveen o nos han vendido confianza
ahora la confianza está depositada en
los miembros de la red no importando si
los conocemos o no
esto genera que podamos como ciudadanos
realizar muchísimas transacciones las
que nosotros vayamos definiendo
entonces significa que podemos confiar
en desconocidos por primera vez
y de forma masiva entre ciudadanos por
ejemplo podemos ayudar a que la brecha
entre la gente rica y pobre sea menor en
la riviera maya muchos pobladores
originarios y gente que incluso complot
compró terrenos fue desplazada de sus
territorios por no acreditar la
propiedad de estos terrenos
en cambio los políticos se pusieron a
alterar el cato de tal forma que se
hacían dueños de hectáreas de selva y
por supuesto de terrenos en frente de la
playa pues block change a través de una
plataforma a través de certificados
digitales o contratos inteligentes pudo
haber frenado este estado
esta apropiación
hay una plataforma mexicana que se llama
mi fiel que permite encriptar documentos
hacerlos válidos y generar un título de
propiedad de mi casa o quizá pueda dar
una factura de un auto y también podría
registrar la propiedad intelectual de
millón proyecto de investigación o
invento esto sin ir a un notario sin
recurrir a una institución y ahorrando
me muchísimo dinero porque toda la red
estaría avalando esta información y la
tendría a su mano
además podría ser bastante útil en las
remesas nuestro país recibe bastante
dinero que viene de el extranjero a
partir de las remesas y también en los
desastres naturales el uso más común
sería ir a nuestra unión y hacer pagar
una comisión altísima que puede ir entre
7 o el 20 por ciento también podría ser
una transferencia internacional y ahí me
cobrarían algunas comisiones más el
cambio de moneda pierdo bastante dinero
sin embargo puedo recurrir a otras
plataformas como page que permitiría
hacer simplemente el pago de manera
inmediata y directa a porcentaje que no
llega ni siquiera al 2% en el caso de
los desastres naturales el año pasado en
méxico tuvimos
en septiembre unos terremotos muy
lamentables y muchas organizaciones de
la sociedad civil y gente estaba
realmente dispuesta a donar dinero y
comenzaron a hacerlo ellos estaban
preguntando quiénes eran las personas
más confiables para poder depositar les
el dinero de forma directa en algunos
casos funcionó pero en otros no tenemos
la certeza que haya llegado este monto a
la gente más necesitada una plataforma
de blogs ain habría facilitado todas
estas
movimientos de dinero
a nivel de tecnología cívica blogging
tiene muchísimo potencial sobre todo en
nuestro país por ejemplo podríamos ahora
en julio tener una en la cual podríamos
ver la información del candidato saber
cuál es su trayectoria ver cuál es su
propuesta y una vez que nos hallamos
bien documentado ahí si emitir nuestro
voto el voto estaría encriptado no
podría modificarse lo cual significa que
no habría fraude igualmente podremos
fiscalizar la campaña de todos los
candidatos poder saber a dónde se han
gastado cada peso y cada centavo que al
final proviene de nuestros impuestos
por lo tanto como ciudadanía podemos
generar y ser parte del diseño y la
aplicación de todas las políticas
públicas yo me pregunto quién de esta
sala confía en las instituciones a ver
levanten la mano
ok ahí está un montón de iniciativas
nuevas
bueno abrir la charla comentándoles que
me apasiona el cine y ahí hay también un
potencial enorme casi ninguna industria
se salva de estas modificaciones
tecnológicas imagínense que para que tu
documental se proyecta en una sala
comercial tienes que pasar por
muchísimos intermediadores un agente de
ventas un distribuidor un exhibidor y
luego los agregadores esto al equipo
creativo que son los guionistas los
directores los productores les afecta
porque ellos no reciben gran parte de
estas ganancias en la que dan los
intermediarios siendo que ellos son los
que generaron el producto la idea o el
valor entonces ahora imagínense un
netflix que ya existe que se llama block
movie en el cual podemos pagar directa
ver películas y pagarles directamente a
los creativos y a los autores de que las
han hecho
kodak este año lanzó su plataforma con
agua la cual encriptar imágenes para que
después los autores puedan recibir y
monetizar a través de sus obras con
ok por primera vez la pelota del juego
está de lado las empresas éticas de las
comunidades autónomas y de los
visionarios o los innovadores
tecnológicos
de hecho hay empresas como las
cooperativas digitales que están
apostando por este tipo de incorporación
de block chain que son las cooperativas
pues son empresas donde la toma decisión
no la hace un fundador o un
inversionista sino todos los miembros de
la cooperativa a partir de votar las
todas la decisión que quieran hacer por
lo tanto hay una gobernanza horizontal y
la propiedad y todas las utilidades se
comparten en esta cooperativa
por ejemplo los ciudadanos en berlín se
han organizado para comprar la compañía
de luz y administrar estos servicios en
nueva york se ha impulsado desde la
alcaldía a que existan más de 20
inversión de más de 2.1 millones de
de efectivo para propiciar que existan
cooperativas lideradas por mujeres y
también hay una moneda digital que se
llama el fair coin que es su prueba de
consenso se hace a partir de una prueba
de cooperación y que está pensada para
muchas más compañías o cooperativas en
este caso que sean
que digitales y que inyecte todo esto a
este sistema
yo no creo que blog sea la salvación
para todos como jesus joven que me
promete eliminar los pecados y darme
milagros creo que la realidad siempre
supera la ficción claramente por lo
tanto hay temas pendientes la huella de
carbono que deja bloques grandísimas se
compara a lo que emite un país como
nigeria
entonces tenemos que cuestionarnos
cuáles son los objetivos tenemos que
garantizar que no exista tampoco un uso
malicioso porque estamos frente a
escenarios distópicos muy cerca mucho
más cerca de quizá lo que ustedes se
imaginan podríamos estar gobernados por
máquinas ya sustituyeron primero a las
operadoras a las telefonistas y ahora
tienen unas grabadoras que son
automáticas pero bastante inútiles
entonces hay apuestas a nivel
tecnológico porque las máquinas aprendan
esto lamentablemente nos alejaría de
nuestra esencia humana pero ya están
aquí
será probable que estemos frente a un
cambio del sistema capitalista como dice
douglas rushkoff la tecnología debe
estar a nuestro servicio para aumentar
asistir y ampliar nuestra humanidad no
dejemos que las máquinas nos controlen
con las plataformas de blogs change
hemos comenzado a colaborar a gran
escala y si podemos seguir confiando y
empoderando nos como especie humana
diseñamos futuros
hermosos que valoren otro tipo de
aspectos no sólo el dinero como pueden
ser la felicidad la cooperación el bien
común y la elevación de la conciencia
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]